visite à dare celui qui va poser les
questions battant baba cissé be parce
que en fait c'est le micro qui détecte
labour équin suivre ça c'est comme ça ce
marché une heure nathan là réside alors
je le ferai et sur twitter
c'est dur pour me poser toutes les
questions vous voudrez pas joli cyril
bon je vous demande de répondre sans
détour
est-ce que
pendant que vous étiez en couple vous
avez eu des pensées impures pour une
autre femme où tout être vivant
m
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi je
suis choqué j'adorais de la question
sahraouie
alors elle une réponse simple alors je
vais vous dire oui je vais je vais
revenir vers vous ça démarre trop fort
mais à gattaca djouhri je répondrais
hockey avant avant avant la fin de leur
saveur médaille cyril est ce que tu as
déjà eu une aventure s'est déjà laissé
des huit mois sur le cadre de l'amour
est ce que tu es déjà eu une aventure
avec une fan de l'émission
non franchement là il est mon talon vers
le feu nous sommes vraiment à l'envers
et la côte est de l'île
[Applaudissements]
vraiment que tu veux dire faire on va
faire dans le désarroi je vais poser
c'est sur le thème qu'est-ce qu'on veut
je coule bazire m ont fait le plein
alors alors cette séquence est
complètement profitez-vous saint geoirs
sachez le et une question vous pouvez
sauter a compté 1 que vous allez on est
d'accord hashtag baba détecteur si vous
voulez poser des questions à l'est par
oui ou par non
est ce que c'est vrai que vous êtes en
contact très avancé avec la chaîne w9
pour l'année prochaine oui ou non il m'a
bouffé une patrie mais w9
vraiment je vais quitter ses 8 points et
sur w9 m6 lé par son père si au même si
ce bon pas le seul scénario qu'elle
cherche un groupe m6
ou bien en avance et non
j'étais concentré 1 pourquoi vous dites
ça mais pourquoi vous dites sommes pas
une question que j'entends moi j'entends
parler dans les médias est en train de
livrer je regarde des applications
j'entends des trucs les obligations sur
les applications
tapuach à part une application et lui
les applications moi je traîne dans les
couloirs ça suffit au ace combat va
enquêter sur ba ba oui est ce que tu es
ce que vous voulez dire par là isabelle
les murs on est jeune et je veux dire
par là que c'est un il se dit beaucoup
qu'une proposition vous avez été faites
qui était précisé que finalement vous
avez décliné mais qu'elle était ferme
alors je m'entends très bien avec le
groupe m6 vous le savez et je le dirai
toujours sondés m
et si un jour je dois quitter ses huit
sévère le groupe m6 que j'irai c'est sûr
et certain
et tu peux avoir une question
subsidiaire à la question de raymond oui
qu'est la question suivante si
d'aventuré nous aligner sur le groupe m6
est ce que vous emmèneriez avec vous la
bande actuelle oui le directeur de mont
joli nom à 2,3 n'ont pris que trois noms
près voilà jean michel est ce qu
actuellement votre merguez frétille non
ces jours ci en ce moment non lui il
pense que c'est une vraie merguez était
immense grille a tenu donc ses lecteurs
de mensonges et les basiques
moi je trouve qu'il a jamais aussi bien
marché ce bois sert il avez vous eu un
rapport sexuel
à moins de 72 heures maintenant on fait
vous fait remonter à entre samedi 11h30
et dimanche à 1h du mat racing
je réponds non avait pas de libido quoi
[Musique]
disent ils pas dit oui
va-t-il y avoir une saison prochaine de
tpm p alors je vais vous dire oui
je vais vous dire pourquoi ça chez nous
que ça fait maintenant huit ans que je
suis au quotidienne plus deux ans de
debdou est en fait le record je crois
que le record pour un animateur de
quotidienne en direct ses 9 ans voilà
donc l'année prochaine
normalement on sera sur leur corps des
neuf ans donc voilà bien parce que pour
ça et puis parce que franchement on sera
gamelle ce moment ça oui voilà et que
vous allez manquer que vous allez me
manquer beaucoup ce week-end nous savons
tous que vous étiez marrakech donc au
maroc
quel pays préférés vous votre pays la
tunisie ou le maroc pour un peu répond
qu'ils ont varié au pardon alors j'ai
dit réfléchir entre temps non
a donc préféré la tunisie j'aime
beaucoup
oui je ne peux pas trahir ses com c'est
comme si vous demandez un suédois
s'ils préfèrent le sou la suède ou la
norvège si les fûts doit préférer la
suède s'il adore mais c'est normal c'est
vrai oui s'il est ce qu'il vous arrive
d'envoyer régulièrement des messages
avec emmanuel macron le président de la
république d'échangés intenses ont ainsi
pesé changer quoi le genre j'ai discuté
de sextos nombreux vents
alors au moment de la communication on
est quand même à 75% de mensonges
on répondra sans avoir répondu à ma
question l'a souvent lu dans les
journaux est ce que vous allez vous
présenter aux prochaines présidentielles
c'est vrai oui il paraît qu'on a parlé
de vous dans des conseils de ce très bon
jeu
c'est un oui là on n'a rien dit ouais je
vous le dire séquence tous les maths
embrassons sa non dit oui pour faire
sauter les applis dit oui 10 boules pour
faire sauter des zappings fait dire ou
[Musique]
es ce que vous avez eu des infos là
dessus sur quoi la fia s'il va se
présenter je sais quand même à parler à
l'assemblée nationale au nom et à
l'arrivée c'est dire s'il a été cité
plusieurs fois à l'assemblée nationale à
100 mais c'est fort je ne parviens
savait des choses mais c'est une chose
positive des choses positives
certainement un peu marre de la
politique telle qu'elle est actuellement
donc on a envie de l'animateur populaire
qui pourrait être plus rassembleur alors
mais là j'ai juste dit oui pour le
zapping
alors la question alors c'est dingue
parce que c'était quoi votre question
c'était ce qui vous est déjà arrivé et
en coupe d'avoir des pensées impures
pour une autre femme ou qui s'en va on
va faire plus simple m'a vraiment c'est
un classique la réponse
soyons honnête et je la donne frais en
toute franchise toute franchise
les yeux dans les yeux non bon
impossible lagarde fait peut-être
[Applaudissements]
voilà qui peut